Lordstown Motors at one point the
company was racing to build America's
first all-electric pickup they make them
in Lordstown Ohio I heard the sales are
great it had a design for a truck a
factory to make it in and hundreds of
millions of dollars in investment but
then the wheels fell off Lordstown
Motors its share price plummeted its
namesake Factory was sold off and now
the future of its pickup the endurance
is in question so what exactly happened
to Lordstown Motors
our story starts somewhat unsurprisingly
here Lordstown Ohio 2019 General Motors
have been making the Chevrolet Cruise
here for years but a drop in sales led
to the company wanting to close the
plant which led to protests and Drew
criticism from then president Donald
Trump what's going on with General
Motors get that plant open or sell it to
somebody and they'll open it GM did just
that they gave a new EV startup a 40
million dollar loan to buy the plants
complete with machinery for 20 million
dollars the startup will be named after
the neighborhood itself Lordstown Motors
its founder was the former chief
executive of another fledgling
Automotive startup called Workhorse a
man named Steve Burns we think we're
going to do the impossible here Burns
license to vehicle design from his
former company Workhorse and set about
entering the race to build the first EV
pickup and remember this is before
Ford's F-150 Lightning or rivian's r1t
had been released our first vehicle is
the endurance of electric pickup truck
on to the factory and the design for a
truck all the company needed now was
money so in August Lordstown announced
it intended to go public through a
merger with a special purpose
acquisition company and invest a
sentiment around the company soared
lifted like many others in the EV Market
by a wave of investors on the hunt for
the next Tesla but also partly because
the company said it had around 27 000
pre-orders plus 75 million dollars of
investment from GM the financing that
comes from being publicly listed is the
last piece we needed as we marched
towards production in 2021 but
lordstown's ride was about to get a lot
bumpier
in the early hours of January 13 2021 an
endurance caught fire on a road in
Michigan while being tested by Lordstown
Engineers Lordstown said the fire was
due to non-conforming Parts on the
Prototype battery and before long the
company's share price began to Tumble
around that time several top Executives
at Lordstown sold off chunks of their
own stock though the company later
concluded there was no wrongdoing and
that the sales were made for reasons
unrelated to the performance of the
company then came the bidding for a
United States Postal Service contract
for a fleet of new electric vehicles now
Lordstown hadn't submitted a bid to
design and build those trucks but
remember Workhorse well it had and it
was expected to manufacture those trucks
in lordstown's Factory but then Oshkosh
defense of Oshkosh Wisconsin has been
awarded the production contract for the
postal services Next Generation delivery
vehicles Workhorse didn't win and
Lordstown shares tumbled further but it
still had further to fall
in March short seller Hindenburg
research accused Lord's town of
misleading investors on among other
things How firm its pre-orders were
saying that many of them were largely
fictitious the report led to a
Securities and Exchange Commission
inquiry and later a Justice Department
investigation and although then CEO
Steve Burns told wsj in March 2021 that
the report contained half truths and
lies and denied misrepresenting the
order book he eventually resigned after
a board committee found inaccuracies in
the company's pre-orders I tried to
reach Burns for comment but I was unable
to do so finally by the middle of 2021
the company announced that it didn't
have enough funds to begin full
commercial production Lordstown needed
money fast
enter Foxconn yep the Taiwanese iPhone
manufacturer the company had said it had
Ambitions to assemble EVS for a variety
of customers on a contract basis much
like it does with its phones Foxconn
wanted a factory and Lordstown needed
Capital so the two companies struck an
agreement Lordstown would sell its
namesake Factory to Foxconn for 230
million dollars and Foxconn would build
lordstown's vehicle that was the plan
anyway production finally started for a
while and then stopped again shortly
after when the company found a problem
with some of its electrical connectors
we filed paperwork with the national
highway traffic safety administration to
voluntarily recall the endurance
nordstown recalled all vehicles that
were out in the wild all 19 of them and
shortly after the company's share price
which at one point had been over thirty
dollars fell below one dollar and stayed
there for more than 30 days triggering a
de-listing notice from NASDAQ that led
to Foxconn saying that Lordstown had
breached its agreement and that Foxconn
would back out of the deal if the matter
wasn't resolved to try and fix the issue
Lordstown announced that it was doing a
reverse stock split merging 15 shares
into one to try and raise the price
above one dollar oh and just before all
that happened another Lordstown vehicle
caught fire this time a test vehicle in
storage Lordstown said it would
investigate the cause
all that brings us to the present day
Lordstown has said it hopes its reverse
stock split will lead to Foxconn
returning to the deal if Foxconn does
then there may be hope for the endurance
yet but if it doesn't and Lordstown
can't find other funding the company
says it may seek to file for bankruptcy
protection I spoke to Foxconn and
Lordstown but neither would comment on
the deal but within its SEC filings lies
another big hurdle Lordstown says the
cost to build the endurance is currently
and expected to continue to be
substantially higher than its selling
price and that makes what happens next
for Lordstown even more challenging in
the three years that the company has
been navigating its various production
modes others including Ford and rivien
have been delivering their EV pickups to
customers and More Trucks among them the
Chevy Silverado EV are on the way and
with the cheapest Silverado set to be
around twenty thousand dollars cheaper
than the endurance not only has
Lordstown lost the race to be first but
it may now struggle to compete or
together
foreign
[Music]